good morning John in 2010 YouTube
celebrated itself with a thing called
YouTube Rewind at that point this was
just a top 10 list of the most popular
YouTube videos of the Year something
that you could do back in 2010 when a
viral video was something that happened
maybe once a week and not a hundred
times per day like it does now but
YouTube Rewind really became itself in
2012 with a video that brought lots of
top YouTubers into physical Studios
together to be a part of the memes I
remember feeling quite left out that I
was not a YouTube Rewind that year or
the next year so we did manage to slip
into what may have been the peak of the
series rewind 2014 which is a Vibe even
re-watching that though it's clear that
there is a problem already a YouTube
video was moving away from being a genre
of content and toward being a kind of
content to illustrate what I mean by
that and the shift that really happened
between 2016 and 2018 allow me to
propose to you a thought experiment
Spotify rewind a single video that
attempts to encapsulate the entire music
Industries year in six minutes no one
wants this because it does not make any
sense now starting in 2016 Spotify
started to do something that people
actually liked then and continue to like
now rapt is a recap of what you liked
not like what happened in music that
year what you enjoyed in music and
podcasts now on YouTube in 2016 things
were simple enough that people were like
yeah okay a fair number of these folks
are people I have some affinity for or
at least familiar with but by 2018 the
story of YouTube was very big very
complex and had been really quite full
of Scandal and more than anything a
YouTube video was not a genre of content
anymore it was a kind of content it was
not a single Community anymore it was
many communities and many of those
communities disliked each other they had
to have known that people would not like
it but in the way of large companies I'm
sure a lot of people looked at it and
they said this is bad but it's the thing
that we do and we've done it so let's do
it now in response to it being the most
disliked YouTube video ever in 2019 they
just did like another top 10 video
except with more production value and
people also disliked that it was clear
to me at that point that there would
never be a YouTube Rewind and there was
not another YouTube Rewind
I would like to propose
that we bring it back now people are
annoyed by Spotify wrapped they will say
Spotify rap sucks either because they
don't use Spotify and annoys them to
feel left out or because they think that
like your taste in music doesn't make
you an interesting person but I am
neither of those kinds of person and I
actually think that Spotify raps
delivers a ton of value to the people
who make content the people who use the
platform and the platform itself it
seems to be a huge win it shows me who I
love which I actually don't know I don't
know what YouTuber I watch the most of
it gives people content to share if they
would like to that's great promotion for
Spotify and for the musicians and
podcasters who are featured and I think
that it gives especially smaller
podcasters and musicians a chance to
feel appreciated and to connect with
their audience I think that this is what
YouTube Rewind should be and I think
that they should just call it YouTube
Rewind I think that that's great a
breakdown of my year on YouTube who did
I watch who did I like is there a
Creator who basically like I'm a bigger
fan of them than anyone else because I
bet I am I bet I'm gonna like 0.1
percent of a few creators any comments
have you left how many videos have you
liked how many super thanks and super
chats have you sent and in a perfect
world there's a chance for me to type a
message to my favorite Creator and then
the day after YouTube Rewind happens
creators get their own rewind that gives
them all their stats and a few messages
from people who appreciate their content
I think Spotify wrapped does good things
for the audience the creators and the
platforms and I think for the people who
find it annoying they're part of the
discourse too it's a fun day and it
fixes all of YouTube rewinds original
problems that it had to pick winners
that it had to try and portray YouTube
in a particular way that was maybe not
consistent with how we were imagining it
and of course with YouTube no longer
being anything like a unified culture
and so YouTube if you're listening put
me in coach my Consulting rates are high
they consist entirely of donations to
Partners in Health John I will see you
on Tuesday